OFFICIALLY COMMENTED ON THAT
STORY YET EITHER.
A MAJOR BLOW TONIGHT TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
A JUDGE RULING THE
ADMINISTRATION MUST REINSTATE A
TRUMP ERA MANDATE THAT BIDEN
SCRAPPED EARLIER THIS YEAR.
THIS AS FOX NEWS GETS AN
EXCLUSIVE LOOK AT HOW ONE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS DEALING WITH THE
RECORD MIGRANT SURGE AT THE
BORDER.
CHIEF CORRESPONDENT JONATHAN
HUNT HAS THE STORY TONIGHT AGAIN
FROM LA JOYA.
>> WE WILL SEE A LOT OF
ACTIVITY.
>> NOT JUST THE U.S. BORDER
PATROL STRETCHED THEN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IS UNDER PRESSURE, TOO.
OFFICERS LIKE SERGEANT GAZA WITH
THE LA JOYA POLICE DEPARTMENT
OUT EVERY NIGHT TOUGH TERRAIN
NEXT TO THE RIO GRANDE BACKING
UP BORDER AGENTS AND LENDING A
HELPING HAND TO MIGRANTS WHO ARE
FREQUENTLY DISORIENTED,
DEHYDRATED AND DESPERATE.
>> I'M AFRAID MYSELF.
SOMETIMES WHEN I SEE THESE KIDS,
IT'S HEART BREAKING THAT THEIR
PARENTS PUT THEM THROUGH THIS.
>> SERGEANT GAZA SAYS HE DIDN'T
TRADE TRAIN FOR THIS BUT HE AND
HIS FELLOW OFFICERS HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO STEP UP WHEN THE
NUMBER OF MIGRANTS CROSSING THE
BORDER EXPLODED THIS YEAR.
>> 2 OR 300 SOMETHING WE WEREN'T
USED.
TO SAY [INAUDIBLE] PATROLLING
OUR CITY STREETS.
AND NOW, WITH THIS, IT'S
OVERWHELMING.
>> MANY OF THESE MIGRANTS
CLAIMING ASYLUM MAY NOW BE DEALT
WITH AS THEY WERE UNDER THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
RETURN-TO-MEXICO AND TOLD TO
WAIT THERE UNTIL THEIR ASYLUM
CASE IS ADJUDICATED.
THE SO-CALLED REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SCRAPPED EARLIER
THIS YEAR.
THE FIFTH CIRCUIT OF APPEALS ON
THURSDAY UPHELD AN EARLIER COURT
DECISION ORDERING PRESIDENT
BIDEN TO REINSTATE THE POLICY AS
EARLY AS TODAY.
>> IT'S THE LATEST IN A SERIES
OF LEGAL SETBACKS FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WITH MANY OF THE
COURTS NOW HEARING THESE CASES
PRESIDED OVER BY JUDGES
APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP